las imágenes de un productor musical
afro francés siendo golpeado y según el
tratado de manera racista por la policía
de parís han despertado la ira de muchos
cuatro oficiales fueron suspendidos y el
ministro del interior de francia dice
que los responsables serán juzgados
esto ocurre tan sólo días después de que
el veedor de la policía el gp n
comenzará una investigación por los
oficiales que desalojaron violentamente
a unas personas de un campo de
emigrantes en parís pero los críticos
del ign dicen que la institución
necesita ser reformada porque hace parte
del ministerio del interior y no es
independiente de la policía cep elige pn
que es el cuerpo de investigación debe
ser verdaderamente independiente para
que no tengamos trabajadores que hagan
parte de una misma administración
juzgando se los unos a los otros
estas investigaciones deben ser
completamente independientes por el
veedor de la policía francesa recibe
cerca de 5000 quejas de ciudadanos cada
año en contraste su par británico maneja
más de 30.000 reportes anuales de
presunta mala conducta policial
este último sólo contrata a civiles y es
alabado por su transparencia
bélgica y dinamarca también tienen
vendedores independientes para
monitorear la policía mientras que en
países como españa portugal e italia el
sistema es más parecido al francés